ils sont en sang pour sang et foyer des
Québécois
d'abord et avant tout pour fidéliser la
clientèle
sont surtout déjà en 2003 l'épicerie
constate que les détails en alimentation
ont décidé de concurrence et les grandes
marques nationales elle travaille là-bas
c'est le professionnel il y a pas de
maison au Québec
tu n'as pas une tête générer des revenus
supplémentaires et on peut être aussi un
grand attrait pour fidéliser les
consommateurs si leurs propres produits
sans bon sens créatif à bon prix en plus
[Musique]
de quelques produits de base il y a 20
ans les chaînes sont passés à des
milliers produits on a
ans
c'est celle qu'on voit croître de plus
en plus depuis quelques années tu as
dire de créer des innovations qui ne
sont pas des copines qui ont polar
équivalent en marque nationale je pense
entre autres à toute la collection loin
on choisit président certain des
nouveaux produits chez IGA plusieurs des
produits irrésistible chez Métro sont
vraiment des recettes qui ont été créé
pour l'entreprise pour cette marque là
et qu'on ne retrouve que là pour la
majorité l'argument prix de Marc
l'argument numéro 1
en 2009 l'épicerie constaté en achetant
près d'une vingtaine de produits de
marque maison plutôt que leur équivalent
de marque national on économise 27 %
nous avons refait le même exercice et
aujourd'hui on économise avec les mêmes
produits près de 30,2 % aujourd'hui il y
a encore un écart de prix à la faveur
des marques maison sur bon nombre de
produits
depuis quelques années les marques
nationales les grandes marques sont
offertes à prix réduit plus souvent
qu'avant c'était et c'est encore
aujourd'hui une stratégie en réaction en
fait ou développement des marques maison
pour essayer de garder une place dans le
panier
Nutrition Santé Environnement de goût
d'expérience vice de forme aussi c'est
là où on se trouve a gagné la référence
dans les produits de marque maison
puissante et ou à valeur nutritionnelle
ajuster
aujourd'hui l'offre de produits santé ou
à valeur ajoutée est devenu
incontournable Loblaws à ajouter PC bios
PC simplement bon PC à base de plantes
métro à Sagan irrésistible music se
déclinent en simple naturellement bio
sans gluten et pension vers une
catégorie qui suscite le plus d'intérêt
et celle des produits à base de plantes
on part les augmentations de 1415
pourcents de C4 50 sur les produits à
base de plantes j'ai 67 % des gens qui
consomme c'est quoi son flexitarien donc
ça marche et
qui ne sont pas attachés
et
je pense que
que nos produits sont en ligne avec les
tendances respectueuse de
l'environnement et aussi des valeurs
sociales c'est tout mais avance
inquiétez pas nécessairement ou si prisé
avant ils sont essentiels aujourd'hui
j'ai la caisse de 140 jours 240 jours en
moyenne
en plus des différentes sous-marque qui
ne donne pas l'impression d'être une
marque maison les chaînes et tante aussi
leur gamme de produits par des
acquisitions première moisson est Adonis
appartient de ta métro les boulangeries
à l'aube la Kim Phat et Ricardo a sauvé
privé mais c'est une excuse et vous
[Musique]
malgré leur popularité grandissant au
Québec les produits de marque maison de
sac à part que 18 à 22 % des parts de
marché ce qui représente quand même un
produit sur 5 vendu mais en France c'est
1 sur 310 en Suisse en Espagne et au
Royaume-Uni c'est un produit sur deux
dans la
maison
et je suis convaincu
[Musique]